in this segment we start a discussion of
multiple continuous random variables
here are some objects that were already
familiar with but exactly as in the
discrete case if we are dealing with two
random variables it is not enough to
know their individual PDFs we also need
to model the relation between the two
random variables and this is done
through a joint PDF which is the
continuous analogue of the joint PMF we
will use this notation to indicate joint
PDFs where we use F to indicate that we
are dealing with a density so what
remains to be done is to actually define
this object and see how we use it let us
start by recalling that joint pmfs were
defined in terms of the probability that
the pair of random variables x and y
takes certain specific values little X
and little Y regarding joint PDFs we
start by saying that it has to be
non-negative however a more precise
interpretation in terms of probabilities
has to wait a little bit
joint PDFs will be used to calculate
probabilities and this will be done in
analogy with the discrete setting in the
discrete setting the probability that
the pair of random variables falls
inside a certain set is just the sum of
the probabilities of all the possible
pairs inside that particular set for the
continuous case we introduce an
analogous formula we use the joint
density instead of the joint PMF and
instead of having a summation we now
integrate as in the discrete setting we
have one total unit of probability the
joint PDF tells us how this unit of
probability is spread over the entire
continuous two-dimensional plane and we
use it we use the joint PDF to calculate
the
ability of a certain set by finding the
volume under the joint PDF that lies on
top of that set this is what this
integral really represents we integrate
over a particular 2-dimensional set and
we take this value that we integrate and
we can think of this as the height of an
object that's sitting on top of that set
now this relation here this calculation
of probabilities is not something that
we are supposed to prove this is rather
the definition of what a joint PDF does
a legitimate joint PDF is any function
of two variables which is non-negative
and which integrates to 1 and we will
say that two random variables are
jointly continuous if there is a
legitimate joint PDF that can be used to
calculate the Associated probabilities
through this particular formula so we
have really an indirect definition
instead of defining the joint PDF as a
probability we actually define it
indirectly by saying what it does how it
will be used to calculate probabilities
a picture will be helpful here here is a
plot of a possible joint PDF these are
the X and y axes and the faction being
plotted is the joint PDF of these two
random variables this joint PDF is
higher at some places and lower at
others indicating that certain regions
of the XY plane are more likely than
others the joint PDF determines the
probability of a set B by integrating
over that set B let's say it's this set
integrating the PDF over that set
pictorially what this means
is that we look at the volume that sits
on top of that set but below the PDF
below the joint PDF and so we obtain
some three-dimensional objects of this
kind and this integral corresponds to
actually finding this volume here the
volume that sits on top of the set B but
which is below the joint PDF
let us now develop some additional
understanding of joint PDFs as we just
discussed for any given set B we can
integrate the joint PDF over that set
and this will give us the probability of
that particular set of particular
interest is the case where we are
dealing with a set which is a rectangle
in which case the situation is a little
simpler so suppose that we have a
rectangle where the x-coordinate ranges
from a to b and the y-coordinate ranges
from some c to some d then the double
integral over this particular rectangle
can be written in the form where we
first integrate with respect one of the
variables that ranges from A to B and
then we integrate over all possible
values of y as they range from C to D a
particular interest is the special case
where we're dealing with a small
rectangle such as this one a rectangle
with sizes equal to some Delta where
Delta is a small number in that case the
double integral which is the volume on
top of that rectangle is simpler to
evaluate it is equal to the value of the
function that we are integrating at some
point in the rectangle let's take that
corner times the area of the
little rectangle which is equal to Delta
square so we have an interpretation of
the joint PDF in terms of probabilities
of small rectangles joint PDFs are not
probabilities but rather they are
probability densities they tell us the
probability per unit area and one more
important comment for the case of a
single continuous random variable we
know that any single point has zero
probability this is a game true for the
case of two jointly continuous random
variables but more is true if you take a
set B that has zero area for example a
certain curve suppose that this curve is
the entire set B then the volume under
the joint PDF that's sitting on top of
that curve is going to be equal to zero
so zero area sets have zero probability
and this is one of the characteristic
features of jointly continuous random
variables now let's think of a
particular situation suppose that X is a
continuous random variable and let Y be
another random variable which is
identically equal to X since X is a
continuous random variable Y is also a
continuous random variable however in
this situation we are certain that the
outcome of the experiment is going to
fall on the line where x equals y all
the probability lies on top of a line
and a line has zero area so we have
positive probability on a set of zero
area which contradicts what we discussed
before
well this simply means that x and y are
not jointly continuous each one of them
is continuous but together they're not
jointly continuous essentially joint
continuity is something more than
requiring each random very
to be continued by itself for joint
continuity we want the probability to be
really spread over two dimensions
probability is not allowed to be
concentrated on a one-dimensional set on
the other hand in this example the
probability is concentrated on a
one-dimensional set and we do not have
joint continuity